[Music]
when people hear about social distancing
and as you called it physical distancing
I think people are confused or worried
what about the people that are actually
in the house with them family kids
parents whatever it is that might have
to go out and then come back into the
house yeah
yeah that's a risk that you that we run
and that the Chinese ran when they you
know lock down nine hundred and thirty
million people in their countries since
January the 25th so typically what you
do is is you you try to compress all of
your shopping fact Americans should
begin to be doing that right now instead
of going out three times a week to buy
stuff go out once a week compress
everything minimize the amount of time
you're out and about when the person
does go out they should ideally try to
wash their hands frequently not press
elevator buttons the Chinese have all
these ingenious things where when you go
into an elevator there's like a little
pin cushion of toothpicks and you take a
toothpick you press your button and then
you discard the toothpick so that you're
not touching buttons because the the
virus can spread on smooth surfaces
that's called fomites so so a person
leaving the household should do that if
someone in the household does get sick
and they are tested positive you can in
principle isolate that person for two
weeks from other members of the
household or in the worst case scenario
they infect the other people in the
household but nevertheless it's them
constrained to one household keep in
mind that most people infected by this
pathogen do fine you know it it the
great majority of people will have no
symptoms or will have minor symptoms
some people however may be twenty five
percent overall will get serious will
get sick and of those maybe a fifth of
those so total of five percent maybe of
the people infected will get seriously
ill and then of course on average we
don't know exactly how many of the
people who are infected will die and the
reason again we don't know is we don't
have good testing so we we don't know
what the what the denominator is we
don't know you know of 10,000 people who
are infected we know that because they
were tested let's say what happens to
them
and how many of them get sick and how
many of them need ICU care and how many
of them die we don't know that
denominator accurately but our best
estimate is that of those infected some
are between half a percent and one and a
half percent will die and and it is
that's a large number but it's very
graded by age so if you're younger than
25 your risk of death is very small
maybe 0.2% that's a big risk for a young
person but nevertheless it's a small
risk and then middle-aged people around
50 or 60 it's about 1% and then above 80
it's about 20% so it's a very steep
curve with age have run we're obviously
in some unchartered territory with
coronavirus and our plan here is to help
you make as much sense of the situation
and a non alarmist fashion as possible
if you're looking for reliable
information from experts on the front
lines of the pandemic check out our
coronavirus playlist which will keep
adding updates - right over here and to
get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe